es werden unzählige energie anlagen in
deutschland entstehen hier
unterschiedlich viel strom liefern je
nach wind und sonne und es wird
insgesamt viel mehr strom unterwegs sein
müssen wir zeigen wie das neue stromnetz
dafür aufgestellt werden muss warum
stromspeicher eine wichtige rolle
spielen und welche probleme es beim
netzausbau noch zu lösen gibt
2050 wollen wir in europa klimaneutral
sein vor allem weg von gas und kohle hin
zu den erneuerbaren energien
notwendig für die energiewende ein
aufwendiges leitungsnetz es muss den
strom effektiv über deutschland
verteilen und gut an das europäische
netz angeschlossen sein unser
strombedarf wird sich in den nächsten
jahrzehnten wohl verdoppeln gründe sind
etwa die e-autos und die wärmepumpen
stadt gasheizungen ebenso die
digitalisierung die immer weiter gehen
wird und die industrie setzt auf
wasserstoff als neuen brennstoff die
herstellung verbraucht viel strom wenn
das alles klappen soll müssen dafür in
den nächsten jahren noch über 12.000 200
kilometer leitungen bereitgestellt
werden locker zwei mal könnte man damit
deutschland umrunden bestehende
leitungen sollen dabei digitalisiert und
erweitert werden andere ganz neu gebaut
werden
insgesamt sind erst rund 2700 kilometer
in arbeit oder fertig heißt der
überwiegende teil muss erst noch
genehmigt und zu ende geplant werden
die leistungsfähigsten trassen
stromautobahnen genannt funktionieren
mit gleichstrom hier geht auf dem weg
weniger strom verloren als sonst für den
transport umgewandelt sollen so die
riesigen mengen windenergie aus dem
norden nach süden kommen
insgesamt muss das stromnetz flexibler
und intelligenter reagieren können denn
die stromversorgung wird eben nicht mehr
einfach von großen kraftwerken geregelt
[Musik]
strom kann man nicht einfach sammeln er
muss effektiv gespeichert werden und das
gilt besonders für das neue netz riesige
speicher müssen darin abrufen zwischen
der sehr wechselhaften erzeugung und dem
unterschiedlichen verbrauch je nach
tageszeit und gegen damit in hochzeiten
die leitungen nicht überlastet werden
und andererseits keine versorgungslücken
entstehen
ein beispiel
2021 wurden ort link fertig eine
kabelverbindung zwischen deutschland und
norwegen das ziel puffern überschüssiger
deutscher willen strom fließt nach
norwegen dafür stehen dort die
wasserturbinen länger still und erzeugen
erst wieder strom wenn er wirklich
gebraucht wird bei windflaute in der
nordsee funktioniert es dann umgekehrt
stadt zu speichern kann man strom auch
wenn andere energieträger umwandeln das
soll vor allem wasserstoff sein der kann
dann auch gelagert werden
trotz allem werden noch einzelne
kraftwerke mit fossilen brennstoffen
weiterlaufen als not puffer damit unsere
stromversorgung wirklich sicher bleibt
[Musik]
die neuen leitungen müssen deutlich
schneller genehmigt und geplant werden
ohne die bürger innen zu vernachlässigen
für anwohner innen und film muss es auch
finanziell lukrativer werden das neue
stromnetz mitzutragen in staatlichen
fördermaßnahmen
für den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
werden macht sich baustoffe benötigt
auch metalle wie nickel
expertinnen befürchten dass der ukraine
krieg und die sanktionen und für längere
zeit lieferengpässe verursacht so geht
mehr denn je nur so viele leitungen wie
nötig und so wenige eingriffe in die
landschaft wie möglich zum beispiel wenn
schneisen durch wälder geschlagen werden
müssen eine neue leitung darf auch nicht
mehr über bewohnte gebäude gespannt
werden je nach magnetischen felder
leitungen wird ein mindestabstand
berechnet bei den großen trassen sollen
erdkabel bevorzugt werden sie sind dann
unauffällig aber aufwendiger und teurer
zu verlegen die landwirtinnen sind auch
hier teils skeptisch wegen der wärme und
strahlung der stromkabel und ein meter
fünfzig unter ihren feldern
die energiewende schneller anzugehen
dafür ist der politische druck jetzt
gestiegen mit großen herausforderungen
das ganze muss sich finanziell rechnen
und technisch effizient funktionieren
das gilt auch für das stromnetz der
zukunft